I think glass is crazy but in a very
good way I think he's very smart I think
he knows what he's doing people think
he's a sadist or whatever it's like my
trail film a flair for the dramatic I
think bit of a sassy man lies can drown
a true backwoods rebel of Tennessee
created one of the world's most grueling
foot races one that is so challenging it
leads many to assume it must be an act
of sadism are you a sadist
no no I think people are obsessed with
comfort to the point that they forget if
you don't have any discomfort in your
life how do you know when you feel good
The Barking marathons is a 100 mile race
comprised of five 20-mile loops which
you have 60 hours to complete it's over
some pretty rugged terrain it's got a
massive amount of climb about 66,000
feet you have just your map and compass
it's cold it's wet it's miserable you're
alone the fact that they'll probably
almost certainly fail makes it more
appealing this started in 85 and we've
had 14 finishers yeah we always use a
camel because that's about the best
cigarette I think
[Music]
the course is located in frozen head
State Park home to the Brushy Mountain
State Penitentiary a location not chosen
by chance
in 1977 James Earl Ray the man who
killed Martin Luther King jr. made
headlines again when he escaped the
prison in the 54 hours he was free he
only made it eight miles from his cell
because this terrain is no joke
Don Dyson man you can put together a
race course that would really challenge
people's soul I think every runner would
like to do better than James Earl Ray
and get further than eight miles
although some of them don't everybody
gets a big number for each loop there's
paperback books which are kind of
strategically placed so that to get them
all you have to follow the course and
you pull out the page number that
matches your bibs you have to turn your
pages to show that you've done the
course he has a brilliant sense of humor
he's parodying the sport of ultra
marathon running those of us who run
ultras we have a certain egoism that we
think we're pretty good because of what
we can do and so he set out to puncture
that balloon Laz keeps making it harder
because he's trying to put it at the
limit of human possibility
[Music]
after they decided that they've had
enough and quit
we played caps on the bugle both because
caps is what you play for someone who's
died in action and because they they're
being tapped out
I think genuinely in his heart he wants
to see people succeed when people
actually finish five loops and you see
him at the end he's so excited and an
ef-1 or more of them comes in it's an
inspiring thing it's hard to believe a
human can accomplish that
it's good that some years no one
finishes because the bark we should win
sometimes too
[Music]